this is entertainment tonight honey so
we're getting to the bottom you know
this relationship
nananana last week I decided to open up
about my feelings I have to be the ones
talking about the elephant you Alan I
we need to talk about your celebrity
relationship you said you're gonna wait
to see how things went in the real world
we're in the real world is are you guys
still you know we're talking you're
still talking she's in Japan right now
oh god I'm about going and there's
different time difference is hard the
real world is hard the world sucks yeah
no it is it's like everything yeah
really quite works after no I just need
my defense I'm going on two different
things I do have feelings for you
[Music]
and I really feel like I'm falling
through
like the whole scene with you guys are
kissing I'm like The Bachelor
wait me so no work I'm a bachelor fan so
I know how these things work what do you
think Whitney's input anything I don't
know she's jealous of people yeah and
he's a good-looking guy that was
good-looking his blimp and I'm obviously
secrets the real world is I give it a
like a clear has been two weeks already
hard for you knowing that you're at
uh-oh in real life now with like Val and
Jenna planning a wedding like that bomb
yeah it's like all these couples you
know what I mean halfway married happily
married and you're just how I feel yeah
do they have to go to japan like the
kojiki laughs you're gonna come and see
the show
yeah of course yeah
[Music]